Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. welcome back to the rest is history where we are on part two of our epic journey into the trial and execution of charles the first with professor ted valence of roehampton university so ted just talking about your background because listeners can't see this but ted has this splendid background of the of the trial which i like to think is his real wallpaper yes at home no we really approve this kind of upping the game definitely we had we had dan jackson in his his top hat and now we've got ted with this sensational wallpaper so before we talk about the sort of the judges as it were let's talk about the the scene in the in the trial and
感谢收听《历史的余烬》。想要收听每周独家加更节目、无广告音频、抢先体验系列节目，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区吗？请访问 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。欢迎回到《历史的余烬》，本期我们邀请到了罗汉普顿大学的泰德·瓦伦斯（Ted Vallance）教授，继续我们的史诗之旅，探讨查理一世的审判与处决之旅的第二部分。泰德，我们先聊聊你的背景，因为听众们看不到，但泰德的背景非常棒，是关于审判现场的，我愿称之为他的真实壁纸。是的，在家里。不，我们绝对赞成这种提升游戏段位的做法。确实，我们有戴安·杰克逊（Dan Jackson）戴着他的大礼帽，现在我们又有泰德这幅耸人听闻的壁纸。所以，在我们讨论法官之类的人物之前，让我们先来谈谈审判中的场景。
when it opens so the people behind you i mean they're about the the scene in the in the trial and that when it opens so the people behind you i mean they're they're all men in the picture behind you um are the people there i mean are they all men or or is it just a huge mass and a kind of rabble of people do they have to buy tickets do they have to queue up to get their tickets how does all that work so there's a bit of a differentiation between uh cheap seats and you know the the kind of costlier options so there are galleries that are kind of above where the commissioners are sitting uh which would have been accessible from from private residences so this is where the kind of the wealthier uh patrons are coming to they can kind of get a box, like a kind of package. Yeah, yeah. So this is where Anne Fairfax, who makes some,
当审判开庭时，你身后的人——我是说，关于审判中的场景，当它开庭时，你身后的人——我的意思是，他们全都是画里的人，你身后的画里全是男人，呃，那里的人，我是说，他们全都是男人，还是说那只是一大群人、一群乌合之众？他们必须买票吗？他们必须排队买票吗？这一切是怎么运作的？所以，便宜的座位和（你知道的）更昂贵的选择之间还是有一点区别的。有些画廊（也就是观众席）位于委员们坐席的上方，这些座位可以从私人住宅进入。这就是那些比较富裕的赞助人来的地方，他们可以弄到一个包厢，就像某种套票一样。对，对。所以安·费尔法克斯（Anne Fairfax）就是从这些画廊里较高级的座位上，发出一些……
so Thomas Fairfax's wife makes her famous kind of outbursts from, is from these posher seats in the galleries. And then you've got sort of, you know, cheaper seats. Well, so there are two alleged incidents where she interjects. The first is on the opening day of the public proceedings of the trial on the 20th of January, where they're naming the commissioners of the court and they read out Thomas Fairfax's name, but he's not there. And she's reputed to say he has more wit than to be here. And then on the 27th, when they actually condemn the king, and they say they're condemning him on behalf of the whole people of England, Anne reputedly shouts out from the gallery, no, not one in 100, or words to that effect. Now, I should say, this is one of those instances where
也就是托马斯·费尔法克斯（Thomas Fairfax）的妻子，她发出那些著名的插话，就是从这些画廊里较高端的座位上发出的。然后你就会发现，你知道的，有比较便宜的座位。嗯，所以有两次据称她插话的事件。第一次是在1月20日公开审判开庭的第一天，当时他们正在宣读法庭委员的名单，并宣读了托马斯·费尔法克斯的名字，但他不在场。据传说，她大声说：“他可没那么蠢，不会来这里。”然后在27日，当他们真正判处国王死刑时，并且说他们是代表英格兰全体人民判处他死刑时，据传说安从观众席上大声喊道：“不，连百分之一都不到！”或者类似意思的话。现在，我应该说，这是其中一个例子……
there's problems with the sources, because most of these reports of her saying these things come from much later accounts, from early 18th century accounts. But the one on the 27th is probably credible that she said that there. But we do have to bear in mind that there were probably about 2,000 odd spectators in this hall. So imagine the noise in that hall. Again, the February trials, we get more evidence about what it was actually like in terms of what it sounded like because bradshaw has to keep telling witnesses to speak up because it's too hard to hear people so i think it would have actually been quite here hard to hear
资料存在问题，因为她说了这些话的报道，大多来自晚得多、也就是18世纪初的记述。但关于27那次插话的记录，她当时确实说过，这可能是可信的。不过我们必须记住，当时大厅里大概有两千多名旁观者。所以想象一下那个大厅里的噪音。同样，在二月的审判中，关于当时的实际情况我们得到了更多证据，关于听觉上的感受，因为布拉德肖（Bradshaw）不得不一直提醒证人大声说话，因为太难听清人们的声音了。所以我想当时实际上应该很难听清……
and fairfax saying those things we're probably getting reports second hand from people who could you know were next to her or her what she wanted to say later on and so on. So Bradshaw is John Bradshaw, who is a Cheshire lawyer. And he's what? He's president. He's essentially the president. He is the president of the court. So it is a very unusual institution. The High Court of Justice created specially to try the king. Bradshaw is its president. And then with 159 commissioners appointed, although much less than that actually turn up. And these commissioners are basically judge and jury.
安·费尔法克斯说那些话。我们得到的可能只是二手报道，来自那些能够（你知道的）站在她旁边的人，或者是她后来想要说的话等等。所以，布拉德肖就是约翰·布拉德肖（John Bradshaw），他是柴郡的一名律师。他是什么？他是主席。他本质上就是主席。他是法庭的主席。所以这是一个非常不同寻常的机构。为了审判国王而专门创建的高等法院。布拉德肖是它的主席。然后任命了159名委员，尽管实际到场的人数要少得多。这些委员基本上既是法官又是陪审团。
So they're occupying kind of multiple roles within the court. But it is Bradshaw. The commissioners are pretty much silent during the proceedings, They're kind of arrayed behind him. He's directly facing Charles as the trial opens, as it's set out. But it is Bradshaw who basically communicates everything about what the commissioners want and what the commissioners do. Is it true that he wore a bulletproof hat? Is that not true? So I was really hoping that we would get on to Bradshaw's bulletproof hat. I like to oblige.
所以他们在法庭上扮演着多重角色。但正是布拉德肖。在审判开始、按既定程序进行时，委员们在诉讼过程中几乎是保持沉默的，他们排在他的身后。他正对着查理。但基本上是布拉德肖在传达关于委员们想要什么以及委员们做了什么的一切信息。传说他戴着一顶防弹帽，这是真的吗？这不是真的吗？所以我非常希望我们能谈谈布拉德肖的防弹帽。我喜欢满足大家的要求。
Yeah. Thank you for that. So there is absolutely no evidence that he wore a bulletproof hat. And so what's Charles wearing when he comes in on that first day? What's he look like? So there is a painting of him at his trial. One thing is that he's physically aged a lot. His beard is grey. It's a full beard rather than being kind of, you know,
好的，谢谢你。所以绝对没有证据表明他戴过防弹帽。那么查理在第一天进来时穿的是什么？他看起来是什么样的？所以有一幅他在审判时的画。有一点是，他的身体衰老了很多。他的胡子花白了。这是一把浓密的胡子，而不是像……
neat and trimmed as in those earlier, you know, Van Dyck paintings, wearing mostly black, black cloak, black hat. Notably, he refuses, he doesn't take his hat off. Again, another sign that he doesn't, you know, recognise the authority of the court or the authority of the judge before him. And presumably, the people sitting in judgment on him don't remove their hats to him as well.
早期的范戴克（Van Dyck）画作中那样整齐修剪的胡子。他主要穿着黑色衣服，黑色披风，戴着黑色帽子。值得注意的是，他拒绝脱帽。这再次表明他并不（你知道的）承认法庭的权威，也不承认他面前法官的权威。据推测，那些坐在审判席上审判他的人也没有向他脱帽致意。
No, no. So there's a lot of not hat action. There's basically a lot of hat action, yeah. But I think this is, you know, we're making a bit of a joke of it, but this is actually really important and really extraordinary. You know, you just think, again, as you said, this is the anointed king. It's not only that he's before people who are not taking their hats off to him. I mean, at least people like Bradshaw are, you know, fairly upper class
不，不。所以有很多“不脱帽”的动作。基本上有很多帽子戏法，对吧。但我认为这是（你知道的），我们虽然在拿它开玩笑，但这实际上非常重要，而且非常非凡。你知道，你只要想一想，正如你所说，这是受膏的国王。不仅是他面前的人没有向他脱帽致意。我的意思是，至少像布拉德肖这样的人是（你知道的）相当上流社会的人……
people. There are witnesses who are in the bank, as it were, ready to be called up to give the prosecution's case, who are, you know, basically the lowest of the low. We've got kind of a 21-year-old butcher from Shropshire, who's going to give evidence against his anointed monarch. I mean, that's an utterly remarkable reversal of the social hierarchy. This is really saying, you know, putting equality before the law into effect. But then there's this, so in a way, the tables are turned on Charles, because, you know, everything that he stands for is sort of being turned on its head. And yet, sort of the irony is this is absolutely, whatever you think of Charles I, this is his moment of glory
大厅里还有一些证人，也就是随时准备被传唤出庭陈述控方案件的证人，他们（你知道的）基本上是社会最底层的人。我们有一个来自什罗普郡的21岁屠夫，他将出庭作证指控他那受膏的君主。我的意思是，这是对社会等级制度一个极其惊人的颠倒。这实际上是在说（你知道的），将法律面前人人平等付诸实践。但随后，从某种意义上说，局势对查理来说逆转了，因为（你知道的）他所代表的一切都被颠倒过来了。然而，具有讽刺意味的是，无论你对查理一世怎么看，这绝对是他的高光时刻……
in a way, isn't it? That he finds within himself this extraordinary kind of, I don't know what the word is. Is it courage? Is it serenity? He gives this performance. He uses his stammer, doesn't he? He'd always had a stammer and he speaks clearly for the first time.
从某种意义上说，不是吗？他在自己身上发现了这种非凡的——我不知道该用什么词。是勇气吗？是平静吗？他奉献了这样的表现。他利用了自己的结巴，不是吗？他一直都有结巴，而这一次他清晰地说话了。
So there's a business with the cane, isn't there, Ted? Is that in the very first day when he taps someone with his cane? Yes, so the prosecuting counsel, John Cook, is reading out the indictment against Charles and Charles says to him, hold. And Cook just carries on anyway. And so the king gets out his cane and taps Cook on the shoulder. And ominously, the top of the cane falls off.
所以这里有个关于手杖的事情，对吧，泰德？是在第一天他用手杖敲了某人一下的时候吗？是的，所以控方律师约翰·库克（John Cook）正在宣读对查理的起诉书，查理对他说：“等等。”而库克不管怎样还是继续读下去。于是国王掏出手杖，在库克的肩膀上敲了一下。不祥的是，手杖的顶端掉了下来。
And this is reported in newsbooks. The Leveller-influenced newsbook, The Moderate, says this is very, you know, well, this doesn't look good for the king the top of his canes come off um so so so yeah um and he waits for someone to pick it up doesn't he and then no one picks no one does yes again again you know but he doesn't lose his self possession though does he i mean you would think that'd be i mean i know frankly putting myself in his shoes i would be kind of shaking and a terrible wreck of a man. But he's not. I think, you know, he shows kind of remarkable control.
新闻书刊对此进行了报道。受平等派影响的新闻书《温和派》（The Moderate）说这非常（你知道的）——好吧，这对国王来说可不是什么好兆头，他手杖的顶端掉下来了……所以，所以，所以，是的……而且他在等别人把它捡起来，对吧，然后没有人捡，没有人这么做。是的，再次……再次（你知道的），但他并没有失去镇定，不是吗？我的意思是，你会觉得这会是——我知道坦率地说，如果换作我站在他的立场上，我会浑身发抖，成为一个彻底崩溃的废人。但他没有。我认为（你知道的），他表现出了非凡的控制力。
And, you know, as you've noted, Tom, you know, the stutter goes. It's a very eloquent defence. I think it's very smart politically as a defence as well. Because he's not just returning to, you know, Charles I of the 1630s, I'm king, do what I say, my way or the highway. He reframes himself as being the man of the people, the defender of the people's liberties, and the defenders of, you know, the ancient constitution, the way things were. And now it's his opponents who are the innovators, the people who want to destroy things and tear things up.
而且，正如你所注意到的，汤姆（Tom），（你知道的）结巴消失了。这是一场非常雄辩的辩护。我认为从政治角度来看，这也是一次非常聪明的辩护。因为他不仅仅是回到（你知道的）1630年代的查理一世——“我是国王，听我的，要么服从，要么滚蛋”。他给自己重新树立了形象，把自己塑造成了人民的代言人、人民自由的捍卫者、以及（你知道的）古代宪法和事物原有运行方式的捍卫者。而现在，他的反对者反倒成了革新者，成了那些想要摧毁一切、撕裂一切的人。
And in that sense, he's got a case, though, hasn't he? I mean, can't he reasonably say, you are an – you know, you're the product of a coup, you're an arbitrary military court, you know, I am the anointed king and you have no authority to try me. Yes. So I think, you know, that's the other thing. He does have a really strong case to make. They try and sort of consult with lawyers in December of 48 to sort of find out what the kind of legal basis might be.
从这个意义上说，他确实有理，不是吗？我的意思是，难道他不能合情合理地说：“你们是一群——（你知道的）你们是一场政变产物，你们是一个专断的军事法庭，（你知道的）我是受膏的国王，你们没有权力审判我。”是的。所以我想（你知道的），这就是另一回事了。他确实有非常充分的理由。他们在48年12月试图与律师商量，以找出法律基础可能是什么。
And basically the kind of overall legal opinion is, you know, there isn't a legal way of, you know, trying your king. The English law doesn't, you know, factor this scenario into consideration. So he's got really good grounds and there are claims that are made, you know, statements about England being an elective monarchy, which is very, you know, easy for him to sort of challenge and dismiss. So he's on strong grounds here, which is another thing I'm sure, you know, that sort of helps to build his own confidence in the position that he's maintaining.
基本上，总体的法律意见是（你知道的），没有一种合法的途径来（你知道的）审判你的国王。英国法律没有（你知道的）将这种情景纳入考虑范围。所以他有非常充分的理由，而且有人提出了一些说法，（你知道的）关于英格兰是一个选任君主国的声明，这对他来说非常（你知道的）容易进行质疑和驳斥。所以他在这方面很有底气，这也是另一件我确信（你知道的）有助于增强他对所坚持立场的自信的事情。
And Ted, on top of that, isn't it the case that the things that he's accused of, that he's the occasioner, the author, continuer of the said unnatural, cruel and and bloody wars and they're in guilty of all the treasons murders rapines burning spoils desolations damages and mischiefs to this nation acted and committed in the said wars are occasioned thereby i mean the fact that he's the author of all of them it seems a bit of overkill well so i think this is where it gets more interesting and i think this is where we do have to think a little bit more about the basis on which the trial is being conducted and so the the ground sort of for the trial and thing in english common law that you know that can't be sustained really but what they're really going for is a basis more on um the laws of war and contemporary understandings of the laws of war and the idea of command
泰德，除此之外，难道不是吗？他被指控的那些罪行——他是上述非自然、残酷和血腥战争的发起者、始作俑者、延续者，并因此犯下了上述战争中实施和犯下的一切叛国罪、谋杀罪、强盗罪、焚烧罪、掠夺罪、荒废罪、破坏罪和对这个国家的危害罪——我的意思是，事实是他是一切罪行的始作俑者，这似乎有点小题大做了。好吧，所以我想这就是它变得更有趣的地方，我认为这也是我们确实需要更多地思考审判所基于的基础的地方。因此，审判的理由以及英国普通法中的某些事情（你知道的）根本无法维持下去，但他们真正追求的是更多地基于……
responsibility. So the idea that the king, as the commander of the royalist armies, has been responsible ultimately for all of the bloodshed in the civil wars. And one of the reasons why they're doing that is that actually the king has given them, he's made a bit of a concession anyway. So after the Second Civil War, Parliament basically reopens negotiations with the king in the so-called Treaty of Newport. And one of the things that the king does during the discussions in the Treaty of Newport is concede the Parliament's argument that it was waging a defensive war, that it was waging a defensive war against the King. So he basically agrees to that point. Why does he do that? Well, at this point in time, he's pretty desperate. And I think he's, you know, he's
战争法以及当代对战争法的理解，还有指挥责任的概念。因此，国王作为保王派军队的指挥官，最终应对内战中的所有流血事件负责。他们这样做的原因之一是，实际上国王已经给了他们一点让步，无论如何他已经做出了某种妥协。所以在第二次内战之后，议会基本上在所谓的《纽波特条约》（Treaty of Newport）中重新开启了与国王的谈判。国王在《纽波特条约》的讨论中所做的事情之一，就是承认了议会的论点，即议会发动的是一场防御战，议会是在针对国王发动一场防御战。所以他基本上同意了这一点。他为什么要这么做？好吧，在那个时间点上，他非常绝望。而且我认为他（你知道的）……
already worried about the army wanting to basically kill him. It's also a point, I should say, that they say that all of these things are going to be worked out in the final conclusions of the Treaty of Newport. And the Treaty of Newport is never concluded. So this is something that he sort of concedes early on in negotiations and he might have rode back on later on. But they've got that in the bank, basically. They've basically got his concession that he made in the Treaty of Newport. And so what a lot of these witnesses they wheel in say is they saw the king when the royal standard was raised at Nottingham to sort of signal the official kind of beginning of hostilities. They saw the king in armour with sword in hand, various battles, so they can show that he was there personally
已经担心军队想要彻底干掉他。我还应该说，这也是他们说所有这些事情都将在《纽波特条约》的最终结论中得到解决的一个时间点，而《纽波特条约》从未缔结。所以这是他在谈判初期妥协的一点，他可能在后来又反悔了。但他们基本上已经把这一点握在手心里了。他们基本上掌握了他在《纽波特条约》中做出的让步。所以他们拉拢上台的许多证人都说，当诺丁汉竖起王室旗帜以发出敌对行动正式开始的信号时，他们看到了国王。他们看到国王身穿盔甲、手持长剑出现在各种战役中，因此他们可以证明他曾亲自到场指挥。
in command. They're establishing that he is the man who was responsible for starting the war. He is the man who was responsible for prosecuting the war. Right. But it's still, I mean, when you've been through a civil war, generally, you know that it's kind of more complicated than that, isn't it? Yeah, but they're not going to admit that, Tom. I mean, I know they're not, but it's still, it seems a good point on which Charles could base a defence. But of course he doesn't.
他们在确立他就是那个负责挑起战争的人。他就是那个负责将战争进行到底的人。没错。但即便如此，我的意思是，当你经历过一场内战时，一般来说，（你知道的）事情要比那复杂得多，不是吗？是的，但他们不会承认这一点的，汤姆。我的意思是，我知道他们不会，但这似乎仍然是查理可以借此进行辩护的一个好切入点。但当然他没有。
He won't defend himself. He's not defending himself. He doesn't recognise its legitimacy. And so he comes before the court on the 20th of January. Yes. Which is a saturday right i think uh and then he probably oh yeah sorry back on the monday um yeah and then he's found guilty on the 25th 27th so he's he's he's um in in private session. They condemn him on the 26th. And then on the 27th, that condemnation is made before him. But he wasn't there on the 26th, was he?
他不会为自己辩护。他没有为自己辩护。他不承认其合法性。因此他在1月20日来到法庭。是的。那是个星期六，对吧？我想，呃……然后他可能——哦，对，回到了星期一，呃……然后他在25日、27日被判有罪。所以他被……在闭门会议上。他们在26日判处他死刑。然后在27日，这一宣判在他的面前正式做出。但他26日不在场，对吧？
Because he kicked him out after three days. Yes, yes. So 23rd, 24th and 25th, when they're hearing kind of witness testimony, the king is not present for any of this. And one argument is actually that, again, this is the hearing of witness testimony. The king is not present for any of this. And one argument is actually that, again, this is a, the hearing of witness testimony is a delaying strategy. And again, they're hoping that this,
因为他们在三天后把他赶出去了。是的，是的。所以23日、24日和25日，当他们听取证人证词时，国王根本没有出席。一个观点实际上是，同样地，这也是……听取证人证词是一个拖延策略。同样地，他们希望……
allowing this extra time, the king will be, you know, mullet over and come back and enter in a plea, which doesn't happen. And at that point, Ted, but let's imagine we had tons of questions about alternatives. So Tim Vasby-Burney, top vicar, friend of the show, member of the Restless History Club, he says, you know, were there other alternatives to executing him, imprisoning him, sending him to exile and so on?
通过留出这额外的时间，国王会（你知道的）仔细斟酌，然后回来并进行抗辩，但这并没有发生。而在那个时候，泰德，但让我们假设我们有很多关于“如果”的问题。所以蒂姆·瓦斯比-伯尼（Tim Vasby-Burney），顶级牧师、节目的好朋友、《历史的余烬》俱乐部成员，他说（你知道的）：“处决他、监禁他、将他流放等等，难道没有其他替代方案吗？”
Had he adopted a different strategy on day one? Had he, let's say, I mean, obviously he'd have had to be a different strategy on day one? Had he... Let's say... I mean, obviously he'd have had to be a different person. But let's say he'd arrived on day one and said, I do acknowledge the court. You know, I've made mistakes. I've learned valuable lessons. Lessons have been learned.
如果他在第一天采取了不同的策略呢？如果他，比方说——很明显，他必须在第一天采取不同的策略？如果他……比方说……我的意思是，很明显他必须是一个不同的人。但假设他在第一天到达时说：“我承认这个法庭。（你知道的）我犯了错误。我吸取了宝贵的教训。教训已经吸取了。”
I was well advised by my staff. I was possibly sent emails but I probably didn't read them before the party um if he'd if that had happened would there have been a different outcome so would they have said oh well in that case you know life imprisonment or or something or if what if he turned up and said you're right i abdicate or whatever what would have happened so i think this is you know as i say it's been a big area of debate amongst historians um i i still i think there's
“我的工作人员给我提出了很好的建议。可能有人给我发过电子邮件，但在派对开始前我可能没读。”如果那样的话，如果发生了那种事，会有不同的结果吗？所以他们会说：“哦，好吧，那样的话（你知道的）无期徒刑或者别的什么”？或者如果他出现时说：“你们是对的，我退位”或者诸如此类的话，会发生什么？所以我想，正如我所说，这在历史学家当中一直是一个争论的焦点……我仍然认为……
still a slim possibility that there might have been a an outcome of him being found guilty and a kind of you know effectively he has to abdicate, goes into prison. His son Henry becomes a kind of puppet king. The issue with that as a possible outcome, I think, again comes back for me to the rank and file of the army. So one of the most extraordinary things, which interestingly enough isn't recorded in the parliament's own recording of the trial in the in the the journal the manuscript journals the trial in state papers is that on the 22nd of january the court is directly approached by army petitioners and what the army petitioners basically say is, we support you, you are caught doing God's work, you are the people's court, but if you don't proceed against the king,
仍然有微乎其微的可能性，结果会是他被判有罪，并且（你知道的）实际上他必须退位、入狱。他的儿子亨利（Henry）成为某种傀儡国王。在我看来，作为可能结果的这一选项所带来的问题，再次回到了军队的普通士兵身上。所以，最不寻常的事情之一——有趣的是，议会关于审判的官方记录（即档案手稿日志）中并没有记录这一点——是在1月22日，军队请愿者直接接近了法庭。军队请愿者基本上说的是：我们支持你们，你们在做上帝的工作，你们是人民的法庭，但如果你们不继续对付国王……
then you're going to be destroyed and we're going to be destroyed as well. And you must proceed against him as a tyrant, you must, you know, get rid of this dreadful, dreadful tyrant. And as I say, noticeably, interestingly, that isn't recorded in the trial journal, but it brings home the way in which the army leadership are struggling to contain the army rank and file as well, and the anger within the army rank and file against the king too. So I think there's a real risk that if they hadn't gone through with executing Charles I, that army discipline could have disintegrated. So, Ted, one other question from Brixton Andrew. So, Brixton, we've got to have him.
那么你们就会被毁灭，我们也会被毁灭。你们必须以暴君的罪名起诉他，你们必须（你知道的）除掉这个可怕、可怕的暴君。正如我所说，值得注意的是，有趣的是，审判日志中没有记录这一点，但这凸显了军队领导层同样在努力控制军队普通士兵的方式，以及军队普通士兵对国王的愤怒。所以我认为存在一个真正的风险，即如果他们没有将处决查理一世进行到底，军队的纪律可能会瓦解。所以，泰德，布里克斯顿的安德鲁（Brixton Andrew）还有一个问题。所以，布里克斯顿，我们必须提到他。
What was on trial, King Charles as a personality or the monarchy as an institution? By the time of the trial, is it the very idea of monarchy that is being tried? I think it's certainly political authority. And there's a lot of signalling, I think, as well, towards a Republican future to, you know, in that, you know, the new coat of arms within the trial, in the way in which the trial kind of inverts the kind of established and accepted political order. I mean, you know, as I say, if we imagine that the King had entered into a plea, the fact that he would have been, you know, listening to testimony against him from, you know, these lowly witnesses is just, I think, you know, really remarkable kind of example of that. So there is a lot more going on here than just trying, deal with a bad king. Yeah. Okay. So he is sentenced to death by the court.
受审的是作为个体的查理国王，还是作为机构的君主制？到审判之时，受审的是君主制这一概念本身吗？我认为这肯定是对政治权威的审判。而且我认为，也有很多迹象表明（你知道的）走向共和制的未来——（你知道的）在审判中出现的新徽章中，在审判颠覆既定且被接受的政治秩序的方式中。我的意思是（你知道的），正如我所说，如果我们想象国王进行了抗辩，他将不得不听取来自（你知道的）这些卑微证人的对他的不利证词，我认为这（你知道的）绝对是一个非常显著的例子。所以这里发生的不仅仅是审判、对付一个糟糕的国王。是的。好吧。所以他被法庭判处死刑。
Does that come as a surprise to him? You know, does he think that he might call that bluff? I think at the beginning of the trial and during the trial himself, he's already in a way sort of prefiguring this casting of him as a martyr. He's already talking about himself in those terms. I think at the beginning of the trial, he understands that that's likely to be the conclusion. But at the same time, he's still trying to kind of win political points and sort, win political arguments. When we get to that last day of the trial on the 27th, and when Bradshaw won't let him speak after the sentence has been delivered, I think that's the
这对他来说是个意外吗？（你知道的）他是否认为自己可以吓退对方？我认为在审判开始时以及审判期间，他已经在某种程度上预先塑造了自己殉道者的形象。他已经在用这样的词汇来谈论自己。我认为在审判开始时，他明白这很可能是最终的结局。但与此同时，他仍在试图（你知道的）赢得政治积分和（你知道的）赢得政治争论。当我们到达审判的最后一天，即1月27日，当布拉德肖在宣判后不让他说话时，我认为那是……
point where we finally see Charles's composure actually break, where he can't, he almost, you know, he, in a way, I think, you know, he knows that it's the likely outcome. But when it's finally there, he can't quite believe it. He can't quite believe that actually they're not going to sort of pull back from this. They're not going to ultimately have second thoughts. So he's convicted on the 27th of January, 28th and 9th. They need signatures for the death warrant. And how easy is it for them to get signatures, to get people to dip their fingers in the blood?
我们最终看到查理的镇定真正崩溃的时刻，他无法——几乎（你知道的）——从某种程度上说，我认为（你知道的）他知道这是可能的结果。但当它真的降临时，他还是有点难以置信。他简直不敢相信他们居然不会从这一步退缩。他们最终不会回心转意。所以他在1649年1月27日被定罪，28日和29日。他们需要死刑令的签名。他们获得签名、让人们把手指浸入血中有多容易？
Well, so there's all sorts of stories about this. The death warrant itself, the copy that is preserved in the parliamentary archives, does show evidence that the subscriptions, the signatures, are taken over several days rather than it all being done in one go. And there are stories which are recounted post-restoration of Cromwell forcing people to sign, holding their hands to the death warrant. There are then stories after they've signed of ink being flicked at people's faces and kind of hysterical laughter that they've done this, that they've taken this step. We have to, I think, you know, take these statements with a pinch of salt because the people making these statements are on trial in 1660 and they're on trial for
好吧，所以关于这一点有各种各样的故事。死刑令本身——保存在议会档案中的那一本——确实显示出有证据表明，签署、签名是分几天完成的，而不是一下子全部完成的。而且有王政复辟后重新讲述的故事，说克伦威尔强迫人们签名，按着他们的手在死刑令上签字。还有人在签名后向人们脸上弹墨水的故事，以及他们完成这一步、采取了这一行动后的歇斯底里的笑话。我认为我们必须（你知道的）对这些说法持保留态度，因为发表这些说法的人在1660年面临审判，他们是在为……
their lives. So they've obviously got a vested interest in saying, yeah, they held my hand when I signed it. I was forced to do this. The other thing we should note is that there are 59 signatures on the death warrant that more than that number stood up to show their assent when Charles I was condemned. Very brave of the ones who stood but didn't sign. Yeah. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman.
自己的生命受审。所以他们显然有既得利益去说：“是的，我签名时他们抓着我的手。我是被逼的。”我们还应该注意的另一件事是，死刑令上有59个签名，当查理一世被判刑时，站起来表示赞同的人数远远超过了这个数字。那些站起来却没有签名的人非常勇敢。是的。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。
And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com.
我们共同主持《娱乐的余烬》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这里有你每周必看的娱乐新闻、评论以及八卦爆料。在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐业的神秘面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚成立了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告音频、加更节目以及现场门票的抢先购买权，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。
That's therestisentertainment.com. Charles has been moved, hasn't he? Because they're going to be building the scaffold. So he's been moved to... And he's, what what burning his papers and talking to his kids and stuff is that basically yeah so he has he has sort of tearful um final sort of um interviews uh with his children um in which in particular with henry he says you know you must never accept the crown um um you know from uh if you're told to do so by the parliament henry promises that he won't
网址是 therestisentertainment.com。查理已经被转移了，对吧？因为他们要搭建行刑台。所以他被转移到……而他（你知道的）在烧毁文件、和孩子们说话等等，基本上就是这样？是的，所以他确实进行了（你知道的）催人泪下的……最后一次（你知道的）……与孩子们的会面……其中特别是对亨利说，你知道的，你绝对不能接受王冠……（你知道的）如果议会叫你这么做的话。亨利答应他不会……
um yeah so the fateful day arrives 30th january can you talk us through the events of yes extraordinary day yeah so i mean it it it takes place the the scaffold is erected outside the banqueting house, which is obviously, you know, filled with symbolism because this is the site of these royal entertainments, these court masteries. So where would it be now? Not on Whitehall? Not the road that goes past the banqueting house?
是的，决定性的日子来临了，1月30日。你能为我们讲述一下是的，那非凡一天的事件吗？是的，所以它发生在——行刑台是在宴会厅（Banqueting House）外面搭建的，显然（你知道的）这里充满了象征意义，因为这是举行皇家娱乐活动、宫廷假面舞会的地方。所以它现在会在哪里？不在白厅（Whitehall）吗？不在经过宴会厅的那条路上吗？
Where exactly? This is a tough question to ask on a podcast, isn't it? That is the site, isn't it? Yeah, no, that is where it would... So it's literally on a house. So where would? That is the site, isn't it? That is where it happens. So where would it... By the war memorial or by the cenotaph or something? So the side that is facing the street, this is where it took place.
究竟在哪里？在播客里问这个问题很难，对吧？那就是那个地点，对吧？是的，不，那确实是……所以它实际上在一栋房子上。那么会在哪里？那就是那个地点，对吧？那就是发生的地方。那么会在哪里？在战争纪念碑（War Memorial）或者阵亡将士纪念碑（Cenotaph）附近什么的？所以面向街道的那一侧，就是在这里发生的。
He walks out of one of those windows onto the scaffold that's been built out there. The reason why they're holding it there, though, is not for the symbolism of executing the king outside of his place of great court entertainments with the magnificent ceiling of you know the apotheosis of yeah of james the first symbol of divine right kingship it's actually for security reasons because um where they execute the um people who are condemned in March of 49. So James, Duke of Hamilton, they execute him in the palace yard. But the crowd at Hamilton's execution is estimated to be about 20,000. So that would have been far too many people for them to feel confident about being able to control the crowd if there was an attempt to kind of rush the scaffold and you know rescue the king
他从其中一扇窗户走出来，走到在那儿搭建好的行刑台上。然而，他们之所以在那里举行，并不是为了在国王举办宏大宫廷娱乐活动的地方之外处决国王的象征意义——那里有着詹姆斯一世君权神授的丰功伟绩的宏伟天花板——实际上是为了安全原因。因为……他们在1649年3月处决被判刑的人的地方。所以詹姆斯，汉密尔顿公爵（James, Duke of Hamilton），他们在王宫庭院（Palace Yard）处决了他。但据估计，汉密尔顿行刑时的围观群众大约有2万人。因此，如果有企图冲向行刑台并（你知道的）营救国王的人群，对于他们是否有信心控制住人群来说，人数会远远过多。
so they they're choosing that the banqueting house because it's actually an enclosed sort of square at this point in time which can hold relatively few spectators and which is well controlled by the army well they're not chosen um and they're still them for there's still an enormous crowd i mean if you look at the contemporary uh prints of the execution there are even people depicted sitting on the pitch of the roof of the banqueting house so right on the top of it trying to to get a view of this extraordinary scene but but the the worry about security does that tell you that they know it's quite unpopular i mean london is a parliamentarian city so you would think if they're going to execute the king anywhere london's the the perfect place to do it
所以他们选择宴会厅是因为它实际上是一个封闭的……在当时是一个可以容纳相对较少旁观者并且能被军队很好控制的正方形广场。好吧，他们没有选择……而且那里仍然有……那里依然聚集了庞大无比的人群。如果你看看当时关于行刑的版画，甚至还有人被描绘坐在宴会厅屋顶的坡度上，就在最高处，试图一睹这非凡的场景。但是，对安全的担忧，难道这说明他们知道这非常不受欢迎吗？我的意思是，伦敦是一座议会派城市，所以你会认为，如果他们要在任何地方处决国王，伦敦就是完美的地方。
but are they still conscious that among the public at large this is probably very unpopular is that what they're thinking is yes yes and all the way through i mean the trial there are also you know um great security measures that are taken um to to ensure that the king can't be rescued. But then, Ted, doesn't that, they think they're the representatives of the people. So if you are, I mean, maybe this is a theme that recurs in history. If you are the embodiment of the popular will and you have to have massive security because you're worried that the people will storm the scaffold and rescue the man of blood doesn't that don't they see the those are obviously the wrong kind of people
但他们是否仍然意识到，在广大公众中，这可能非常不受欢迎？这才是他们的想法吗？是的，是的。而且自始至终——我的意思是，在审判期间，也采取了（你知道的）严密的安全措施，以确保国王无法被营救。但是，泰德，难道不觉得——他们认为自己是人民的代表。所以如果你是——我的意思是，也许这是历史中重复出现的一个主题。如果你是人民意志的化身，却需要进行大规模的安全防范，因为你担心人民会冲上行刑台营救血腥的人，难道他们不认为——那些人显然是错误类型的人吗？
you know well there's there's a great example of this actually is sort of you know if you look at the the level of agreements the people and, and certainly in versions of them, when they come down to sort of who is going to be able to vote in these versions of agreements of people, initially it sounds like every man, every free man will have his vote. And then they think about it and think, well, actually, maybe not servants. No, servants are too kind of wedded to their masters. Okay, not servants, not servants.
（你知道的）好吧，这其实有一个很好的例子——（你知道的）如果你看看《人民协议》（Agreement of the People）的水平，在它们的某些版本中，当它们落实到谁将能够在这些版本的《人民协议》中投票时，最初听起来好像每个男人、每个自由民都可以投票。然后他们仔细一想，觉得：嗯，实际上，也许仆人不行。不，仆人太依附于他们的主人了。好吧，仆人不行，仆人不行。
Okay, well, hang on. What about people who receive charity? No, no, too kind of wedded to their masters. Okay, not servants, not servants. Okay, well, hang on. What about people who receive charity? No, no, no, no. Because they're too, you know, dependent as well. They're not people who receive charity. We'll strike them out. Okay, okay, not them. Okay, what about royalists?
好吧，等等。那些接受慈善救济的人呢？不，不，太依附于他们的主人了。好吧，仆人不行，仆人不行。好吧，等等。那些接受慈善救济的人呢？不，不，不，不。因为他们也太（你知道的）依赖了。不能是接受慈善救济的人。我们将把他们划掉。好吧，好吧，他们不行。好吧，那保王派呢？
Well, not royalists. They're not royalists. Okay, no royalists. Okay, okay. Okay, what about people who don't like the agreement? No, well, we shouldn't have people who don't like the agreement either. So eventually you end up with a franchise that is people who agree with you
好吧，保王派不行。他们不是保王派。好吧，没有保王派。好吧，好吧。好吧，那些不喜欢这个协议的人呢？不，好吧，我们也不应该让那些不喜欢这个协议的人参与。所以你最终得到的选举权范围，其实就是那些同意你观点的人。
and these are the people these are these are the people yeah yeah yeah as dominic says an abiding theme of history so charles is on the scaffold and he's he's he's put on an extra shirt hasn't he so that he won't get cold and people yes that he's he's frightened and he behaves very well yes so so so again you know i think this is as in his trial moment in which he shows great composure and dignity do we know who they we don't we don't know who the executioners are then they wear wigs the executioners to disguise they wear masks and uh yeah so their their their identity is concealed although it's usually thought to have been uh a guy called um richard brandon is the the executioner and so charles neil's but he gives he gives a speech first there doesn't he doesn't he give him yes yes he does give a speech and there is also as there is for the later trials
这些人，这些人，就是这些人，是啊，是啊。正如多米尼克所说，这是历史的一个永恒主题。所以查理走上了行刑台，他穿了一件额外的衬衫，不是吗？这样他就不会觉得冷，人们……是的，他……他很害怕，但他表现得非常好。是的，所以，所以——再次（你知道的）我认为这就像在审判中一样，他表现出了极大的镇定和尊严。我们知道行刑手是谁吗？我们不知道，我们不知道行刑手是谁。他们戴着假发，行刑手为了伪装，他们戴着面具，并且——是的，所以他们的身份被隐藏了，尽管人们通常认为是一个叫……
a a shorthand note taker there to take down um what the king saying. What he's saying. So his final words are recorded. I go from a corruptible crown to an incorruptible crown. I mean, it's impressive. Great stuff. It's great. It is great stuff. And isn't his last word, isn't he? One last word is remember.
理查德·布兰登（Richard Brandon）的人是行刑手。于是查理跪下了，但他首先发表了一段演讲，不是吗？他确实发表了……是的，是的，他确实发表了一篇演讲，而且就像后来的审判一样……有一个速记员记录下国王所说的话。他所说的话。所以他的遗言被记录下来了。我从一顶会朽坏的王冠走向一顶永不朽坏的王冠。我的意思是，这令人印象深刻。太棒了。太棒了。这真的很棒。难道他的最后一个词不是——难道他的最后一个词之一不是“记住”吗？
And then, I mean, I just kind of think, Charles I, obviously, in many ways, was a pretty poor man. But if I'm publicly executed i mean i i can only dream of behaving with this sort of dignity and courage of charles the first on the scaffold yeah he became him all that kind of stuff yes yeah yeah and then there's some there's uh such a groan as i never heard before and desire i may never hear again it's the head bumps and rolls doesn't isn't that some weird story? I mean, it's in 1066 and all that, so it must be true.
然后，我的意思是——我只是在想，查理一世，显然在许多方面是一个相当糟糕的人。但如果我是被公开处决的——我的意思是，我只能梦想能够表现出查理一世在行刑台上那种尊严和勇气。是的，他成就了自己，诸如此类。是的，是的，是的。然后是一声——“一声我从未听过的呻吟，愿我永远不再听到”。那是头颅落下并滚动的声音吗？难道没有这样一个奇怪的故事吗？我的意思是，它被记录在《1066年及所有那类事情》（1066 and All That）里，所以它一定是真的。
That, you know, his head gets chopped off and he wanders around the block for a few seconds. Yeah, that's definitely true. Yeah, yeah. There's a great picture of the headless Charles I kind of discoursing. But do people dip their handkerchiefs in the blood? Is that true?
就是说，他的头被砍掉了，他在行刑台附近徘徊了几秒钟。是的，那绝对是真的。是的，是的。有一张很棒的图片，画的是无头查理一世在……滔滔不绝地讲道理。但是人们把手帕浸在血里了吗？这是真的吗？
Yes, yes, yeah. And, you know, again, going back to those kind of discoursing but do people dip their handkerchiefs in the blood is that true yes yes yeah and you know again going back to those kind of um contemporary uh visualizations of the execution um there's lots of images of people fainting in the crowd uh or you know people with their heads in their hands you know in shock and dismay of what has happened so the crowd so this is different from let's say tom mentioned the execution of louis the 16th and the sort of what has happened. So the crowd, so this is different from, let's say, Tom mentioned the execution of Louis XVI and the sort of classic French revolutionary, you know,
是的，是的，是的。而且（你知道的）再次回到那种……当代关于行刑的视觉表现……有很多图片描绘了人群中有人晕倒，或者（你知道的）人们双手抱头（你知道的）对发生的事情感到震惊和沮丧。所以人群——所以这与——比方说，汤姆提到了对路易十六的处决，以及那类……
the tricoteurs and the crowd roaring and all this sort of stuff, which is obviously we've got from Dickens and Carlyle. But the execution of Charles I, do you think the crowd were pleased? Do you think they cheered and hurrah, the man of blood is dead? Or do you think some of them were upset? Oh, I think certainly people were. I think certainly people were upset. Yeah.
经典的法国大革命场景——无套裤汉（tricoteurs）和人群的欢呼声以及诸如此类的事情，这显然是我们从狄更斯（Dickens）和卡莱尔（Carlyle）那里了解到的。但是对于查理一世的处决，你认为人群是高兴的吗？你认为他们欢呼雀跃、大喊“血腥的人死了”吗？还是你认为他们中有些人感到难过？哦，我想肯定有人难过。我认为肯定有人难过。是的。
Yeah. Yeah. So, I mean, I know this topic we've already asked, but Alex Kleinberg, how did the rest of the population react to the execution? Was public opinion divided? Would you say that basically people are just kind of stunned that it's actually happened? Yeah, stunned, horrified, appalled. And European reaction as well is that this is extraordinary, despicable, terrifying.
是的。所以，我的意思是，我知道这个话题我们已经问过了，但亚历山大·克莱恩伯格（Alex Kleinberg）问：其余的人口对这次处决作何反应？公众舆论是否分裂？你会不会说，基本上人们只是对这一切真的发生了感到震惊？是的，震惊、惊恐、骇然。而且欧洲的反应也是：这非同寻常、卑鄙可耻、骇人听闻。
There's an interesting letter from the Venetian ambassador where he says, first of all, history know, history records no example of the like, this is something that's totally unprecedented. But in the next bit of that letter, he goes on, it basically kind of admonishes, you know, European ruling, you know, has a saying, saying, you know, you spent all your time in your petty squabbles, you know, disputing about your various, you know, privileges and all the rest of it and here is this terrible existential threat that's emerged in england where the idea of monarchy the idea of monarchy itself has now been put on trial and dispatched and is that how it's generally understood because i mean you know in the wake of louisVI's execution, I mean, that's absolutely clear. There's a kind of dread among the monarchs of Europe.
威尼斯大使有一封有趣的信，他在信中说，首先，历史知道——历史没有记录过类似的例子，这是前所未有的。但在那封信的接下来的部分中，他继续写道，基本上是指责（你知道的）欧洲的统治阶层（你知道的）有一句名言，说：“你们把所有时间都花在琐碎的争吵上，（你知道的）争论你们的各种特权以及其他一切，而这里却出现了这样一个可怕的生存威胁，它在英格兰浮现，君主制的概念、君主制本身的概念现在已经被送上法庭审判并被处决了。”这是否就是人们普遍的理解？因为我的意思是（你知道的）在路易十六被处决之后，我的意思是，那绝对是很清晰的。欧洲的君主们中间有一种恐惧。
Do they feel that kind of dread that maybe this is something that might spread or is it just seen as a kind of mad English thing? No, I think there's definitely a fear of contagion also also just you know as i say the extraordinary nature of it and the recognition of how different it is from um you know what is a relatively commonplace uh occurrence which is a king dying at the hands of his own subjects you know a king dying in battle or dying in post-deposition is something that's awful but in a way is kind of recognized as yeah as an occupational risk if you like but but the idea that you're going to be tried by your own subjects and that they're going to assert their authority over you as they take your head off is something that is is extraordinary but here's a weird thing though ted so in some ways you would say this is an incredibly symbolic
他们是否感到了那种恐惧，觉得这可能会蔓延开来，还是仅仅被视为一种疯狂的英国现象？不，我认为绝对存在对传染的恐惧，而且正如我所说，这具有非凡的性质，并且人们认识到它与相对普遍的事件（即国王死于自己臣民之手）有何不同。你知道，国王在战斗中或在被废黜后死去是一件可怕的事情，但在某种程度上被认为是一种职业风险，如果你愿意的话。但你将由自己的臣民审判，并且他们会在砍下你的头时向你宣示他们的权威，这种想法是非凡的。不过泰德，这里有个奇怪的地方：在某种程度上，你会说这是一个具有极其象征意义的
moment um it shows that monarchy is not above the law, that the monarchy is sort of subject to the popular will, all these kinds of things. And yet, obviously, Britain still has a monarchy. And the monarchy is restored in 1660. And could you not argue that in some ways, politically, in the very long run, and in the battle for the public imagination, that this is a disaster for the ante, for Charles's opponents, because it makes him a martyr. And even now, you know, when children read in their school textbooks about the execution of Charles I, it is very hard,
时刻，它表明君主制并非凌驾于法律之上，君主制某种程度上服从于大众的意志，诸如此类的事情。然而，显然英国仍然保留着君主制，并且君主制在1660年复辟了。难道你不能说，在某些方面，从长远来看，在争夺公众想象力的战斗中，这对查理的反对者来说是一场灾难吗？因为这使他成为了一名烈士。甚至现在，当孩子们在学校教科书中读到查理一世的处决时，也很难
as we found in this podcast, it's very hard to tell the story without Charles becoming this tremendous underdog and very admirable. And on that theme, is it not, I mean, the morning of the execution that you get this pamphlet, Icon Basilicae, published, which is supposedly Charles's own reflections. And in reaction to that, you get Milton publishing Iconoclasties, the idea that icons should probably be smashed. He just can't compete in the bestseller stakes.
正如我们在本期播客中发现的那样，很难在不把查理描绘成一个极其弱势且非常令人钦佩的人物的情况下讲好这个故事。顺着这个主题，在处决的早晨，不是出版了一本名为《国王画像》（Eikon Basilike）的小册子吗？据说那是查理自己的反思。作为对此的回应，弥尔顿出版了《砸碎偶像者》（Eikonoklastes），认为偶像大概应该被砸碎。他在畅销书排行榜上简直无法竞争。
No, you know, Icon Basilicae't compete in the bestseller stakes it's it's no that you know um icon basilica is a runaway bestseller and you know far you know exceeds the parliamentarian attempts to to counter it um and i think it's it's not even you know it and in in the long run a problem i mean it immediately becomes a problem for the new regime, if you like, even amongst its own governing class. So they attempt very soon after the King's execution, basically to require everybody on this new governing body, the Council of State, to take a pledge of loyalty, the engagement, which basically says that you agree, as well as pledging loyalty to the new regime, you agree that the execution,
不，你知道，《国王画像》……无法在畅销书排行榜上竞争……不，你知道的，嗯，《国王画像》是一本大卖的畅销书，而且其销量远远超过了议会派试图反击的尝试。我认为从长远来看，这甚至不是一个问题——我是说，它立刻成为新政权的一个问题，甚至在其自身的统治阶层内部也是如此。因此，在国王被处决后不久，他们基本上试图要求这个新的统治机构“国务会议”中的每个人都宣誓效忠，即所谓的“效忠誓约”。该誓约基本上说，除了向新政权效忠外，你还同意国王的
trial and execution of the king was justified, was lawful. And members of the Council of State won't take it, including most notably Thomas Fairfax, who eventually takes a kind of modified version of it um so it's not just that it's you know it's a problem in terms of the wider public um being appalled by this even amongst those who are now in charge there's a great deal of sort of um you know conflicted feelings about what has been done what what they what they've just gone through and it does leave this problem of legitimacy um you know at the heart of this regime there's basically the regime has had to come into power through you know this course of action which essentially many people feel is illegal as well
审判和处决是正当的、合法的。而国务会议的成员们拒绝签署，其中最引人注目的是托马斯·费尔法克斯，他最终接受了一种修改后的版本。所以这不仅是说，它在更广泛的公众中——对这一切感到震惊——是一个问题，甚至在那些现在掌权的人当中，对于已经做过的事、对于他们刚刚经历的事，也存在着大量相互冲突的复杂情感。这确实在政权的核心留下了一个合法性问题。基本上，政权是通过这种行动方式走上权力巅峰的，许多人认为这种行动方式不仅在许多方面是不道德的，而且也是非法的。
as being immoral in many ways because of course when we're using this word regicide regicide is not a crime it is a sin they've committed this heinous sin of of killing uh their anointed king well that so the new seal is 1649 in the first year of freedom by god's blessing restored so yeah so so that's the question isn't it how where what is it that's being restored what is this freedom that's being restored ancient freedoms tom so so from our anglo-saxon but but even going further back than that so so you know milton writes paradise lost the idea of freedoms that go back to man's creation by God? I mean, these are the kind of political and theological arguments that the trial... So we should say, because we've been talking a lot about the horror and the division
因为当然，当我们使用“弑君”这个词时，弑君并不是一种犯罪，而是一种罪过。他们犯下了杀害受膏君主的滔天罪行。好吧，那么新的国玺是1649年“上帝赐福恢复自由的第一年”。所以，是的，问题就在于：正在恢复的是什么？这种正在恢复的自由是什么？古老的自由，汤姆。所以，从我们的盎格鲁-撒克逊时期开始，甚至还要追溯得更远。所以，你知道，弥尔顿写了《失乐园》，其中提到了可以追溯到上帝创造人类的自由的理念？我的意思是，这些就是审判中的政治和神学争论……所以我们应该说，因为我们一直在讨论那种恐惧、分歧
and the anxiety that, you know, in the aftermath of the trial, there are people who get enormously excited about what has happened. And, you know, talking about the garden of in you know eden of course one of those people is gerald win stanley yeah um the digger leader off in surrey um this is kingly power um being brought down the spirit of covetousness and he starts digging doesn't he in the months after that yes yeah after the execution yeah um but then obviously in the long run ted charles's son charles um who's been in exile he returns in 1660 and it's sort of hurrah hurrah the monarchy is back and the regicides
以及焦虑：在审判之后，确实有人对发生的事情感到极大的兴奋。而且，说到伊甸园，当然其中一个人就是杰拉尔德·温斯坦利。是的，萨里的“掘地派”领袖。这就是王权的覆灭，是贪婪精神的打破。他在那之后的几个月里开始掘地，不是吗？是的，处决之后是的。但是很明显，从长远来看，泰德，查理的儿子查理一直在流亡，他在1660年回来了。然后是一片欢呼声，君主制回归了，而弑君者们
so some of them obviously dead obviously most famously cromwell but the ones who aren't are they they're basically hunted down are they then and and forced to face justice yes yeah yeah um so some of them have already kind of fled into exile um because the the king's general pardon um exempt accepts those who are uh had had a part in his father's murder um as as it's framed um and so some of them have to be you know some of them them are taken back from the United Provinces, from the Dutch Republic, and they are brought to trial. Some flee to America, don't they? Yes. So three of them famously escape to New England,
其中一些人显然已经死了，最著名的当然是克伦威尔；但那些还活着的，他们基本上被追捕了吗？然后被迫面对审判？是的，是的，是的。所以其中一些人已经逃亡流亡了，因为国王的大赦令排除了那些曾参与谋杀他父亲的人，正如当时所构建的那样。因此，其中一些人不得不被……其中一些人从七省联合共和国、从荷兰共和国被带回并接受审判。有些人逃去了美洲，对吗？是的。所以其中三人著名的逃到了新英格兰，
William Goff, Edward Wally and John Dixwell. And all of them escape justice. So what they do is actually, certainly, nobody ever finds out, I think, that Dixwell is over there, because he basically goes to the continent, first of all, and they think that he's somewhere in Germany, and they never kind of twig that he's actually gone over to New Haven and is living under an assumed name in New Haven. So in the wake of Charles's execution, there are statues of Charles and of his father James, I think in St. Paul's, and they get taken down and demolished. And there's a statue of Charles I by the Royal Exchange and that gets, again, kind of demolished and it gets beheaded. And they kind of put this inscription on it,
威廉·戈夫、爱德华·沃利和约翰·迪克斯韦尔。他们都逃脱了法律的制裁。他们所做的事情实际上是——当然，我认为从来没有人发现迪克斯韦尔在那里，因为他基本上先去了欧洲大陆，而人们认为他在德国的某个地方，他们从来没有察觉到他实际上已经去了纽黑文，并在纽黑文隐姓埋名地生活。因此，在查理被处决后，圣保罗大教堂里有查理及其父亲詹姆斯的雕像，我想它们被拆除并毁坏了。皇家交易所附近也有一尊查理一世的雕像，同样被拆除并被斩首。他们还在上面刻下了这样一段铭文：
death of the last royal tyrant in the first year of England's liberty restored, 1649. And there's something very French revolutionary about that. The idea that the symbols of monarchy have to be toppled. And yet, ultimately, it's as though it never happened and we've got a fight kind of final question here from ian brocci and this this i mean it sounds a very bad thing to ask at the end of what an hour and a half we've been talking about this but with cromwell becoming law protector and then charles ii restored by 1660 do you think that charles ii's execution while very dramatic was ultimately not terribly
“英国恢复自由第一年的最后一个皇家暴君之死，1649年”。这其中有一种非常法国大革命的色彩，即君主制的象征必须被推翻的想法。然而，最终，这一切就像从未发生过一样。我们这里有一个来自伊恩·布罗奇的最后一个问题。听起来，在一小时半的讨论结束时提出这样一个问题似乎很不合时宜：随着克伦威尔成为护国公，然后查理二世在1660年复辟，你认为查理二世的处决虽然非常戏剧化，但最终并不是非常
significant? Don't say that to Ted of all people, he's writing a book about it. If you compare the impact of Louis XVI's execution with the ideological assault on the idea of monarchy, and you compare it to this, there is obviously a kind of ideological assault, but it's not, it doesn't reverberate very profoundly. And as Dominic said, you know, the monarchy gets restored, we still have a monarchy, we're still, there's still overwhelming support for royalism. Is this something that just gets forgotten? Or does it have a kind of long term effect on American Revolution, French Revolution, and therefore into kind of modern republicanism i mean how how significant is this as a moment do you think i think it's very significant and i think you know i come back to you know the the other question that i that i got
重大吗？别对泰德说这话，他正在写一本关于这的书呢。如果你把路易十六处决的影响与对君主制思想的思想攻击进行比较，并把它与这个进行比较，这里显然有一种思想攻击，但它并没有产生非常深远的反响。正如多米尼克所说，君主制复辟了，我们仍然有君主制，而且仍然有压倒性的保王主义支持。这只是一件被遗忘的事情吗？还是说它对美国革命、法国革命以及现代共和主义产生了某种长远的影响？我的意思是你认为这是一个多么重要的时刻？我认为这非常重要，我想我回到了我从你的听众那里得到的关于弑君者以及他们处于地狱哪一层的那另一个问题，
from one of your listeners about the regicides and which circle of hell they were in i mean it lives in infamy uh to the present day i mean and to the present day we have people who commemorate the death of charles i there'll be people on the 30th of this month going to lay wreaths um the base of his statue at the top of white hall um you know there'll be a solemn procession down white hall um this. This is a remarkable event, which is remembered, you know, through the centuries, mainly being remembered in an English context as a tragedy, as a national disgrace, as something which, you know, there has to be regular kind of, you know, remembering and a kind of atonement for as a nation. I mean, January 30th remained a day in the official church calendar for special prayers up until I think the mid 19th century.
它至今仍臭名昭著。直到今天，我们仍然有人纪念查理一世的死。本月30日将有人前往白金汉宫（注：原文指Whitehall白厅）顶端的他的雕像基座献花圈，白厅将会有一场庄严的游行。这是一场非凡的事件，几个世纪以来一直被人铭记，主要是在英国的语境下被当作一场悲剧、一场民族耻辱来铭记，作为一件作为一个国家必须定期进行缅怀和赎罪的事情。我的意思是，直到19世纪中叶，1月30日一直是官方教会日历中用于特殊祈祷的日子。
So it's something which exerts a really powerful influence in terms of the national memory. But it is also something where we have another narrative going along with it, which is actually that this is a moment in which tyranny is resisted, in which oppressive power is overthrown, and in which liberty, Republican liberty... So that's the kind of campaign... ...is established. Yeah. Yeah, feeding into it. Yeah. And for English radicals, it's always really problematic to acknowledge that and engage with that, even if they did feel sympathetic. It's always it's the place you don't want to go to. I mean, there's the famous Gilray cartoon of the 18th century radical Richard Price as his writing desk. And the sort of symbolized figure of Edmund Burke is behind him with the Bible and, you know, the crucifix coming behind him sort of representing king and church.
所以这是一件在国家记忆中发挥着极其强大影响力的事。但这也是一件伴随着另一个叙事的事，那就是这是反抗暴政、推翻压迫权力、确立自由——共和自由的时刻。所以这是一种运动…………正在融入其中。是的。是的。对于英国激进派来说，承认这一点并参与其中总是非常棘手的，即使他们确实感到同情。这始终是他们不想涉足的地方。我的意思是，那是吉尔雷创作的18世纪激进派理查德·普赖斯在写字台前的著名漫画。象征着埃德蒙·伯克的形象站在他身后，拿着圣经和十字架，代表着国王和教会。
But just, you know, above Richard Price, above his writing desk is this image of Charles I's execution. And the subtitle is the execution of Charles I or The Glory of Great Britain. And so the implication is that all of these sort of reasonable reformers of the 18th century are actually in their hearts regicidal Republicans. So this is something that they're always, most of them, except for people like Paine, trying to distance themselves from a lot of English radicals. So Charles has kind of great posthumous victory in a way. He loses the war.
但就在理查德·普赖斯的头顶上方、他的写字台上方，是查理一世被处决的画像。副标题是“查理一世的处决”或“大不列颠的荣耀”。因此，其暗示的含义是，所有这些18th世纪的理性改革者实际上内心深处都是弑君的共和主义者。所以这是他们——除了像潘恩这样的人之外——大多数人总是试图与许多英国激进派保持距离的事情。所以查理在某种程度上取得了伟大的死后胜利。他输掉了战争，
I think it is a great victory for the royalist cause. Yes, certainly. But it is also something that has an important legacy in Republican circles as well. And I think it is something that is influential internationally as well as within England too. So, you know, it is something that influences the French Revolution. I mean, Louis XVI is famously kind of contemplating the fate of Charles I
我认为这对保王派事业来说是一场伟大的胜利。是的，当然。但这也是在共和派圈子里具有重要遗产的事情。我认为它不仅在英国国内，而且在国际上也具有影响力。所以，你知道，它对法国革命产生了影响。我的意思是，路易十六在受审时，
when he is on trial. It's also something I think that, you know, the American revolutionaries, I mean, Jefferson and Adams were both deeply read in the history of the Civil War. It's something that is part of their DNA. Yeah, thinking too. Well, that's brilliant, Ted. Thanks so much.
曾 famously 考虑过查理一世的命运。这也是我认为美国革命者——我的意思是杰斐逊和亚当斯都对内战历史有深入的研究——这是他们基因的一部分。是的，也有这种思考。好吧，这太精彩了，泰德。非常感谢。
Some amazing stuff, isn't it? To find at the end that it is important. It would be terrible if it wasn't we wasted our time yeah but we haven't at all so thanks so much and when is the book out uh i had no idea the book will be out when when i can actually get to write it yeah no no i mean it's i i changed my byline um when i was doing a literary review um review and I said I'm writing a book very slowly on the trial of Charles I so my hope is that this year
有一些很了不起的内容，不是吗？最后发现它很重要。如果它不重要那就太糟糕了，那我们就白浪费时间了。是的，但我们一点也没浪费，所以非常感谢。请问这本书什么时候出版？呃，我不知道，这本书会在我真正能抽出时间写它的时候出版。是的，不不，我的意思是，当我做文学评论时，我改了我的署名，我说我正在非常缓慢地写一本关于查理一世审判的书，所以我的希望是今年
I might write a couple of chapters and get a book contract together basically and get them signed up so we're talking like you know three or four years down the line okay well worth hanging out for. Thanks so much, Ted. Thanks so much for listening.
我可能会写完几个章节，并把图书合同敲定下来，基本就签约了。所以我们谈论的是大约三四年后的事。好的，非常值得期待。非常感谢，泰德。非常感谢大家的收听。
We will be back very soon with, what are we going to be back with? We've got diseases and we've got Babylon. Yeah. We've got all history. All the stuff. All right. Bye-bye.
我们很快就会回来。我们要讲什么呢？我们有关于疾病的内容，还有巴比伦。是的。我们拥有一切历史。所有的内容。好的，再见。
Thanks so much. Bye-bye. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com That's restishistorypod.com I'm Marina Hyde and I'm Richard Osman and together we host
非常感谢。再见。感谢收听《The Rest Is History》。如需获取独家节目、抢先收听、无广告体验以及加入我们的聊天社区，请访问 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。我是玛丽娜·海德，我是理查德·奥斯曼，我们共同主持
The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therest launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets,
《The Rest Is Entertainment》。这是您每周获取娱乐新闻、评论、一丝八卦的好去处，在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐业的面纱，告诉您这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部。如果您想要无广告收听、独家节目和抢先购买现场演出门票，请访问 therestlaunchourmembersclub.com。如果您想要无广告收听、独家节目和抢先购买现场演出门票，
head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。